I would think of a in an ATV like a ATV
from Camila that's actually a good
that's actually a great question yeah
for Camila
Blake Shelton reveals the presence he
wants from his fellow The Voice coaches
for his retirement from the hit
competition series I think uh from John
I would like a pallet
of lve
with a mixture of his choice but about
not a case a pallet palette all right
I'm with that from Gwen
um
we split everything anyway so whatever
she buys herself her unconditional love
yeah her hand on marriage can I
redecorate the LA house
this is my retirement here
I'll get you an ATM
this comes on the heels of John Legend
Camila Cabello and wife Gwen Stefani
offering their own suggestions this is
crazy because everyone's coming after me
with ideas what should we do and it's
hard to you know he has everything he
has everything but I think his favorite
thing would be a bag of corn like that
would be honestly like he would be so
thrilled
um or fertilizer or something like that
yeah I feel like perfect Parting Gift is
that he has a new show called
barmageddon and I feel like that's his
happy place that's a good Parting Gift
hey I'm Blake Shelton I'm Carson Daly
and I'm Nikki Bella Bella and this is
because he loves alcohol
[Applause]
of our finalists tonight
and Blake has the most wins under his
belt as a coach he's crowned a winner
from his team for eight seasons of the
hit NBC series it's unbelievable and
every season just amazing
best so what will it take to throw him
off his game I think if he has more
people in the finale then it splits his
vote so that's true now we're talking
trees around yeah John Legend knows
everything about math
that's how I won my first season I was
like it was my singer Against All Team
Blake
yeah and uh he split his boat up and
mailing just went right through that
quality over quantity that's what I said
yeah mailing was incredible she was
maelyn doesn't deserved to win indeed
indeed and it's hard to have that many
people in the lives yeah that is true
but I think it is true about the
splitting up especially if you have two
artists that are in the same genre then
you're really
right yeah but before he exits he's
happy just as long as Team Blake or Gwen
wins did you feel more competitive or
less competitive how would you
categorize it more or less more more
competitive you gotta win for the
household yeah
foreign